security will be tight here in New York
City as it gets ready for its biggest
celebration of the year on Friday
organizers unveiled this year's revamped
design of the New Year's Eve Ball that
will set high above Times Square Kenneth
Craig is here with more on the
preparations kind of good morning good
morning to you Dana roughly a million
people are expected to pack Times Square
to ring in the New Year and police are
not taking any chances they've stepped
up security even more this year to keep
all of those people safe preparations
are underway for one of the biggest
celebrations of the year New Year's Eve
in New York City and the end of the
2010s it's a great experience
the NYPD is also making its own
preparations this is gonna be one of the
most well policed well protected
celebrations in the entire world
thousands of police officers will patrol
the streets of Times Square and the
surrounding area most will be visible
and in uniform while others will not be
visible but the security measures will
not stop there explosive canine
detection teams radiation detection
teams bomb squad Response Teams drone
detection and interdiction teams many of
the revelers will be tourists Shirley
Green is visiting from Virginia I've
only seen it drop on TV Green says she's
considering joining that crowd even with
the heightened police presence I would
expect pretty much what I'm seeing now a
lot of people a lot of excitement a lot
of hype workers installed 192 brand new
Waterford crystals to the nearly 12,000
pound new year's ball that will descend
from 1 Times Square when the clock
reaches midnight the theme of this
year's ball will celebrate the gift of
goodwill the Gift of goodwill is the
international sign and symbol of
hospitality of good fortune of course
goodwill and you can see this depicted
on this amazing crystal triangle here
right now the NYPD says there are no
credible threats for any of the events
but they're asking the public of course
to stay vigilant Thank You Kenneth
you